the Joe Rogan experience did you see
that imagine song all those knuckleheads
got together and saying imagine there's
no heaven this is not the time when
everyone's Grammys dying you [ __ ]
idiot to sing imagine there's no heaven
and there's this sense of you feel like
they've that they feel like they did
something yeah netiquette that she's so
happy
she's gal gadot whatever [ __ ] did Wonder
Woman she's got this beautiful smile on
her face and so happy to sing that thank
you just like like she's seducing you
yeah I lost my job at the meatpacking
plant but gal gadot sang it man it's a
terrible version you guys suck at
singing yeah why are you even singing
publicly I didn't even post but I tried
to do one where I first of all I tried
to do that where I go it Majan I just
started laughing hysterically so then I
did one where I go I want to connect
with all you guys so let's just jerk off
together then I go I'm not used to this
hand this hand just try to connect with
all my fans but it's such a dumb move to
I can't believe how many people I mean I
guess that she must have reached out to
them sent me of you singing up and they
want to be like tight with her like sure
Wonder Woman yeah I'll do it yeah okay
okay
I couldn't keep I tried to stay off [ __ ]
stay offline you [ __ ] I try get off your
phone yeah I tried to do it because I
wanted to I wanted all of us to to mock
it I think I have it I think the some
comics did something like that yeah yeah
yeah they did I couldn't wait yeah like
I saw Eric Andre and then like slap on
my slob on my knob that's what they did
right there the exact yeah they're like
yeah dude they did like a parody of it
it was great well it's the weird thing
is you know people are sitting around
going all people think I'm cool if I do
this yeah yeah yeah you know instead of
like just capturing a genuine moment in
your life which is really hard to do on
social media anyway because you feel
like a [ __ ] dork you know it's a
weird feeling for though
like imagine you had worked with Gao
right I thought about this too like you
did something you we're gonna move here
somewhere and then she hits you up hey
I'm trying to do this you have that
moment of pause especially as a common
because it was like so much
self-awareness but you're like oh that's
gonna be lame as [ __ ] and then you have
to like figure out a tactile coaster
just just don't 100% 100% first of all I
could give two [ __ ] whether or not I'm
ever in a movie again ever two [ __ ]
whether or not I talked to her first
like what's up and she's like will you
sing imagine a line from imagine and if
I'm in it friends with her yeah that's
what I'm saying I would have to say
listen you're awesome I think you're
great yeah that is that is a ridiculous
idea yeah it's so lacking in
self-awareness and so we're date I let
me tell you what I would do if I was
even if I wasn't a comic if I saw
someone do that
I'd be like what in the [ __ ] do you
think you're accomplishing with this I
felt so much better today seeing
celebrities singing imagine you made it
better was not really yeah you know
Grammy died choking on her own vomit but
I feel like the world's better because
gal gadot so pretty gal gadot and she
started it off imagine there's no heaven
and then at the end big smile she did it
like a really like sincere look into the
camera like look what I did for you did
she I mean yeah I thought I didn't get
to it she's like hmm I feel connected to
you yeah there's some people man that
get real self-indulgent and
self-righteous with that [ __ ] social
media it's exposed a lot of celebrities
for being real dorks yeah yeah of course
you know they should be exposed for that
but they never got a chance to be
exposed before they would go to
tonight's show they do these things you
do these interviews everything was real
fluff yeah you just leave him alone with
a phone or you get great stuff you see
Tom Hanks wife
singing along to Naughty by Nature I was
really surprised yeah it was good though
it was fun so many good
exceptional yeah yeah no makeup she's
having fun hip hop array here's the
thing that that cadence and like that
that rhyme pattern yes it's not easy to
mimic no it's not easy to mimic no she
did a good job but it's also so obvious
that she wasn't trying to be anything
other than have fun yeah well when
you're drinking children's blood every
night for dinner you have fun you know
well I think sure it helps you keep your
rhythm going
mmm yeah no she was just having fun
that's revealed that she's super cool
yeah with no makeup right yes she's not
trying to get dolled up no like there's
these people that some people are doing
these like quarantined like day five
here we are day five and it's like it's
so contrived and super contrived I guess
they want to connected people and they
want to talk to people but oh I mean
what are we doing yeah I mean are we
doing that what are we doing yeah we are
we are but we're having a conversation
we would have this conversation if there
was no microphone yeah I probably talk a
lot more [ __ ] about people yeah I mean
that's always a big component of a good
time it's fun talking shit's fun
[Applause]